you're the best wife in the world
hey derek
what a defeat man i mean i did not
expect to win by that much but
i warned you i'm a good bowler whatever
all joking aside i want to say that i
actually had fun and i'm really looking
forward to your vote in the spring yeah
i'll just write in [ __ ]
i'm sorry what did you just say just
ignore him he's being a jerk i said
she's a [ __ ]
oh my god what the hell i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry that was awesome i'm so
sorry
oh look oh here's that photo off you
wanted
ow sorry so you know that's everything
that happened so it was just what
happened it was just like
what's wrong with you i don't know i
just i have a lot of adrenaline right
now just take a few deep breaths okay
the guy said he might press charges yeah
well randy i would like you to know that
we will not be pressing charges yeah
that really wasn't an option come on the
guy was being a total jerk what ben did
was warranted and
extremely awesome by the way did you
write down how awesome it was kidney
stone yep big sucker too we're gonna
have to keep him here until it passes
leslie and dr clipperton
wow man i
i'm so glad you guys are meeting it's
like worlds collide you know i love it
i want candy
what is he on morphine it's good stuff
leslie come here do you have any idea
how beautiful you are i'm serious you're
like
a flower or no like a snug bug or like a
a snugger doodle or something like that
we should just go for it you know
life
we have a ceremony we need to be at in
two hours is there anything that we can
do sorry i stay on you're not going
anywhere for at least a day
okay well i'll call mayor stice and
we'll reschedule the ceremony no this
town expects me to was out i'm making
that speech and i'm simply gonna explain
to the crowd that love is everywhere and
they have to surrender to the flow of
the universe you know price's right is
on i think oh you remember staying home
sick from school
watching the presents right
oh god
i would like to point out that we drove
all the way here from pawnee indiana a
city with some class by the way
and sure my husband made an honest
mistake 20 years ago but it was very
meaningful that you were going to
finally be able to forgive him can't you
just give ben a key to the city here now
in your office where no one will know
your shame
sorry babe no worries
i love you
oh
you know what i had my time no i did my
thing i want to be a city counselor and
i did and i was and i i was like and
people were like
at least
we have each other i love you so much i
love you too
this is real i know you're my husband
you're my wife you married me in front
of people i did i was there we may have
peaked but it doesn't matter we need to
do something big you know something that
really lets people know that we're gonna
love each other forever yeah what is it
i got it
hello sir we're sober we would like to
get tattoos in our bodies because we
love each other tattoos this is a pawn
shop
but yeah sure i can do that
[Applause]
look what he's doing he's breaking pens
this is the idea
of the century right here wow
come here
ben
what is the first rule of the leslie
knope emotional support task force
don't let her get a tattoo what the hell
happened i couldn't help it she's so
cute when she's coming up with
destructive ideas
never send a husband to do a best
friend's job out wyatt walk it off walk
it off fine
and you did it yep see you later no nope
sit down
hello everyone thank you all for coming
to this wonderful and calm event our
first item up for bid is to
all access vip passes to the unity
concert let's start the bidding at 40
do i hear 40 thank you 40. we can beat
this 50 anyone for 50 50 thank you sir
terrific any higher
no
well that's fine we're all just calm and
happy people enjoying ourselves together
on earth sold
for fifty dollars how magnificent leslie
that's less than face value you need
passion zeal showmanship i don't have
the gavel so i'm powerless i respect the
hierarchy of the auction i think
leslie's doing a great job thank you
craig hey are you doing that right now
you're gonna do some tai chi i'm gonna
tell you fine leslie is already the
queen of stress so i have to be like her
stress shamwow i wrap myself around her
i soak up all of her stress and then
after the kids are born someone can
squeeze me out into a bucket
i think it's going great you want to
have massage okay
come on pearl jump in don't make me pull
the permits on your rental units hey all
the paperwork on those buildings are
under my dog's name so if you got a
problem take it up with princess honey
why don't you take a whale sounds break
okay i'll finish this up well my
boyfriend might not be moving back for a
while so i have to back out
just wanted to look at it one more time
you know i can't give your deposit back
i know
and there's a 300 all right martha i get
it
actually is there a way i could put down
like a
hey hey
you know you were coming back here oh
what are you doing
oh my god what are you doing
i'm thinking about my future
i am deeply ridiculously
in love with you and above everything
else i just i
i want to be with you forever
so leslie knope
wait wait
okay just
i need to remember this sure give me a
second
leslie no no no hold on just i need
another second please
i need to
remember every
little thing
about how perfect my life is right now
at this exact moment okay
are you good yeah okay i'm good
leslie knope
william yes
marry me oh yeah okay
i call it the pawnee commons celebration
of pawnee's history and people mama poke
themed playground
food trucks from local restaurants
little sebastian fountain i mean it's
perfect thank you i can't see myself
fighting you on more than 60 of these
ideas i'd expect no less i'm just glad
you like it i've never met two people
more passionate about their hometown oh
i'm actually from minnesota why do you
know so much about pawnee well i'm in
love with a woman from here
a strange passionate goofball of a woman
me he's in love with me the time is now
the place is pawnee
let's make history
that was amazing that was a flu-ridden
michael jordan at the 97 nba finals that
was
kirk gibson hobbling up to the plate and
hitting a homer off of dennis eckersley
that was
that was leslie knope
you